in order to take the country back from
the radical left in 2022
the gop needs to put forward a really
ambitious
positive and unabashedly pro-america
agenda
and for months the angle's been telling
you those exact policies
in order to help them win see end all
covert restrictions that remain
forget the mass mandate stop the out of
control spending
keep taxes low get rid of critical race
theory support law enforcement secure
the border
well sounds a lot like the new contract
with america that donald trump is
working on with my next guest
former house speaker newt gingrich he
added
another pillar to politico he said it
should be positive school choice
teaching american history for real
abolishing the 1619 project eliminating
critical race theory
we should say bring it on newt gingrich
former speaker the house fox news
contributor
joins me now newt why is now
the time to resurrect the a blueprint an
idea of a blueprint
that you launched nearly 30 years ago
it's hard to believe
i know it is hard to believe well look i
think that the
radical left has given us an enormous
gift
working with a number of pollsters
we found out that in fact john
mclaughlin in particular
well there are over 30 issues where 75
or 85 percent
of the american people agree and these
are issues where the left is totally
opposed
school choice for example is a 72 or 74
positive with both black and latino
families
who realize that the current school
system simply
isn't serving them you have a number of
other
places after all this talk about racism
and racial division
by 91 to 5 the american people prefer
reverend martin luther king's
proposition that he cared about the
content of your character
not the color of your skin that's like
91-5
you find that in terms of dismissing
this corrupt politicians bill
and insisting that you know who's voting
that you can identify them uh is that
that's about an 88 issue and i think
that part of the problem is
uh republicans don't appreciate the
power
of describing a better future not just
attacking the sick present
and so i think there are things we can
do the ones you mentioned
are exactly in the right direction uh
you know
biden wants to raise taxes 75
american people want to lower taxes now
you can't sustain i mean if we're
competent if we learn the arguments
if we are prepared to be disciplined if
we continually focus on the future
we're going to build an american
majority that is bigger than the
republican party
and we're going to shrink the radicals
to about
15 or 16 percent that's what margaret
thatcher did
that's what ronald reagan did and you've
pointed this out and you've done this in
practice is
focus on the education of our young
people
what is happening in our public
and private schools in the teaching of
history
and the obsession with race in all
subject matter
from that summer reading list of schools
to
the curriculum in the fall this is
populated by
garbage and contemporary literature
which is poorly written and poorly
conceived
and it teaches our kids to dislike each
other not to come together but to
dislike each other and distrust each
other
you're on to something i think i'm
telling you so many mothers are coming
up to me today
complaining about this very thing today
no you're exactly right look i think in
places for example like fairfax county
which is supposedly a very blue county
you go around the county
and you ask parents how they feel about
dumbing down education
how they feel about bringing in racism
we've got to be straight and we've got
to be as clear
and as strong in our language as the
radical left is
the radical left is the most racist
group in america
and we need to say that and take it head
on
and we need to not be intimidated by the
elite media
who are all sucked into this baloney and
frankly are
increasingly out of touch with the
american people
and the american people talk to
themselves and they build an
understanding
and there is i think a hurricane coming
of anti-left-wing anti-radical
anti-racist views where people are just
going to say nonsense
you know either close the schools fire
the people break up the teachers union
but get rid of all of this effort to
brainwash our children
uh and for that matter to brainwash the
military
to brainwash corporate executives i mean
it is pathetic
but it takes a conservatism that is
articulate
is prepared and understands where the
fights ought to be
if you really want to build a huge
american majority now this is
this is absolutely necessary the win win
in next year and in 2024 has to be
overwhelming it has to be a tsunami
so there's no mistake we're not going
back to this nonsense again newt i
cannot wait to see
your blueprint part two the second
chapter
of the contract with america hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else